if you're vaccinated and you see the
case numbers and you're saying i'm gonna
do a trip in two weeks
we now learn about the fact that this
variant is out there
should the average person change their
activity as a result of that
if you're fully vaccinated no if you're
fully vaccinated the good news is
that the vaccines we have hold up very
very well against the delta variant
so if you're let's say you're planning a
trip with four of your friends and
they're all
fully vaccinated do your trip don't
worry about the delta variant
the delta variant you know it poses a
marginal problem for people who are
fully vaccinated not much of one
you just tend to get a little bit more
breakthrough infections but not people
don't get sick because they're fully
vaccinated
delta variant is a huge problem for
people who are not vaccinated
those people are at super much much
higher risk without
you know with the delta variant than
without but if you're fully vaccinated i
wouldn't worry